unlife a pie that was hardly anything
but digital technologies everything is
digital it's almost like the movie
aspect of it it's all moving we've
gotten to a point in technology where
you can actually create something so
naturalistically believable that you
can't tell the difference between the
real and the imagined and in a strange
way it's opened the door to any kind of
storytelling in live action the fact
that you can create a tiger so
believable zette audiences suspend their
disbelief even if you tell them during
the shot they can't del which is the
real tiger in which is the fake the
kennel is saying that we shot on PI I
mean I that wouldn't been possible at
all on film the new sensitivity of the
cameras are just tremendous of picking
up this low-light sensitivity and also
being clear through that transmission of
all the highlights of all the little
candles and knowing all those new office
and then seeing the faces beyond that I
mean that is something that is new with
this technology that we could
achieve before we're kind of in a
situation now where people almost expect
your movie to sound like a real movie
and look like a real movie when it's
still in editorial on the one hand
that's great because it means that you
know we have more control over on the
other hand it means we go home a lot
later in the day but I'm looking at the
page i'm not saying you know and then
something shoots out toward the audience
I was aware from the very beginning that
this story was going to have an epic
feel that it would not have had because
of the three game because we're working
family the entire time i worked on film
or more 3d glasses so i didn't have to
think about 3d i could just watch what i
was seeing and react to it the trick was
not to think oh this is a 3d movie I
better cut it differently but rather
just if I'm experience that in 3d all
the time I can just do what feels right
the same way I was
you